what's up fellow gamers roll the intro
[Music]
ask you guys know Coco melon is taken
over the PewDiePie channel in
subscribers very soon
subscribe subscribe now I'm not gonna be
pity and make silly jokes and jabs just
to gain subscribers I would never do
that instead what we're gonna do this
time is we're gonna fight fire with fire
baby Oh Coco melon has all these kids
songs but Coco melon don't know nothing
about the Swedish kids songs
alright this is what's gonna bring me
back on top Coco melon you may have your
nursery rents but did you have room in
toilet I don't think so
basically this video is just me gonna
look at Swedish nostalgia I'm actually
scared we did this on life strain it was
really Oh God this is fire cocoa melon
no moving darlin oh yes if it'll mean
they're for the kids
[Music]
[Music]
why did I like this a day you move me
take a your movement smooth smooth he
came he was my favorite dude he was so
cool
do you guys have this maybe you have an
American version English version of this
this is technically life Swedish by the
way it's Finnish which is why they speak
so weird
sweet people don't speak like this their
food morning you never know with Moon's
because it's the moomintroll I don't
remember much of this our parents dog
was actually named after her I don't
remember no it was named after the dog
in the movement Charlotte yeah her name
is me my mom dressed me up like her as a
kid I think I told this story I went to
school like this thanks mom
kindergarten kindergarten I thought it
was hilarious she was my favorite like
that's cool kokom Ellen not cool this is
cool bubbles and stuff but then it stood
it's so big
it is so big I never liked to be honest
I never liked movement darling sorry
Finnish people don't like it very much
and I'll tell you why because of the
goddamn [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right nine
million sweets when they hear that name
starts shivering in fear in
post-traumatic stress [ __ ] for those
who don't know with this creature that
lived in the Moomin doll in that valley
of Moomin I don't know why they would
put this thing in there it was
terrifying
stop making spooky things for kids
what's wrong with you this scared me so
much I was scared of going in woods
after this because modern lurked in the
woods this is the episode with modern oh
god it is all God I saw a glimpse I'm in
so they're just chillin right in the
Moomin Darlan playing poker as you do in
women darlin snus memory candy there
Lila means they're moving pop on there
but then ice covers the house god I'm
actually confronting my fears more on
electricity goes out everyone grab some
weapon look at him he just stared ah
that's terrifying they'll make fun of me
he has a freaking gun what shoot him
shoot him this time we want to speak
with you they're trying to teach kids
how to communicate and not shoot each
other yeah that's good that's good
violence bang oh he just wanted a heart
I'd say still shoot him just to be safe
nothing that looks like that should live
good shoosh shoosh Maura did you guys
have anything that terrified you as a
kid I feel like everyone has this for me
another thing which I know you had and I
am baffled that this is allowed The
Muppets Christmas Carol scared me more
than anything I have ever been scared of
amnesia nothing compared to the freaking
Muppet Christmas Carol this movie needs
to be banned
I'm not for banning I'm for freedom of
speech but Muppet Christmas story needs
to go it needs to go I'm done look at
that
this is a kid's film we're about
Christmas the best feeling ever this is
the worst feeling ever stop it stop it I
can't even watch more that's I'm still
scared tonight
another thing that's still scared the
crap out of me was trap door I'm not a
fan of trap door I'm sure you guys had
trap Authority this is the reason why I
can't watch stop motion at @ss
thirty-year-old because of trap door
goddamn trap door
something would always come from the
trap door
it's for kids March I love this stuff
she loves creepy stuff I don't get it
hey back to a more positive note
kokom Ellen you got songs oh really well
did you have the pokemons
intro theme song Ames Swedish and I
gotta say I compared both versions and
the Swedish one sings with so much more
so much more passion love God
um you feel like you feel that the best
Oh big girl or something
where does the power come from it's you
and me they're saying we saved the world
again again is something with Russian
they never saved the world they just
battled pokemons come on don't
overestimate your influence that sense
has always bothered me actually you know
how you manage
it's basically what they're saying do
they tip I gotta say I know I sing well
that makes no sense Pokemon oh god I'm
ruining Pokemon for myself stop it I
don't remember speaking like that
hey catch yeah or there fun fact since I
am studying nihongo pika means sparkly
how about that but makes sense because
pika people doesn't mean sparkling or
shiny I forgot never mind doesn't matter
that sense to submit we know how you
manage what does that mean
it means nothing try again Sweden you're
a Pokemon ruin Pokemon cancelled another
maybe you guys had this
I feel like this video this is gonna be
people out of the box oh my god I had
that or it's gonna be what the get see
show I guess banana apos you may have
figured out the translation its
translation bananas in pyjamas it
actually says in English I never
realized this is me in there in the
Saturday morning I'm not gonna lie I
never liked the show either as a kid you
can't really pick what to watch i it was
there all right and I know other people
like that I don't like when they dress
up what is this give me the cartoons
they're saying cartoons that's a
probably a man in a suit let's get real
here
if moominpappa was here he would shoot
her that's all I'm gonna say about thank
you
good episode good episode really enjoyed
it but that was one theme song to rule
them all boom baby or Nana or as in you
say in English gummy bears that makes no
flippin sense it's boom be banana please
do you understand how confusing it is
growing up watching Swedish cartoons and
then growing up realizing there's an
American version that it's like no this
is this is wrong baby this is how it
goes la Australia
[Music]
I can't believe or some listen that was
a cool kid alright let's just want to
throw that in there for no reason
whatsoever I didn't like boom baby I
don't either
I'm not gonna say it and lied to you
guys I didn't like it I just like -
theme song theme song ten out of ten
baby the show I don't want to tell you
if you liked it that's good enough for
you but you have no taste however that
the creme on the top the stuff that I
liked the most was the stuff I wasn't
allowed to have we weren't allowed to
have Cartoon Network I know it still
hurts what the flip parents they gave me
so many things but they robbed me of
Cartoon Network Dexter's Lab I was
always so fascinated in I would watch it
over at friends house and I was like
this I can't believe this is exist and I
don't have it in my house
see what I was missing out on oh god it
sounds so wrong in Swedish you kids have
been it's and ferb will we had Dexter's
Lab which is apparently still ongoing
Jesus
[Music]
such cool animation style - I know me
and Edgar basically so Felix what did
you like huh well I just said it almost
Digimon yeah yeah yeah I was a Digimon
fan or ice in Sweden we called Digimon
digital monsters Digimon
I remember watching this whole anime one
episode at a time every morning and
during this social distancing I've
really lived that habit of watching an
anime in the morning and it's so good
they had the coolest intro it's got some
cyber stuff going was the main teacher
moan cold
come on or something
go watch fitness and ferb if you don't
like it right man come on man
and like tying would travel differently
on the island so they like they were
there for an entire summer break but in
reality once they came out spoilers they
still had their summer break although
they couldn't see Agora Mon or whatever
his name was
digi evolved to champion digivolve to
what else sounds like a cold world
ultime digi champion evolution to tear
up whatever it was cool I like how they
have all these cool ones and then
there's a freaking cactus and I know
what you're thinking this is just a
blatant ripoff of Pokemon and you're
absolutely right so I wanted to find
what was like the most specific ones for
Sweden and I found this video I never
had that but I remembered that this is
like our South Park basically but I
don't think it was a very edgy the three
friends and Gerry and Gerry
Owen pinger Oh when he went Matt Matt I
was like brah
[Laughter]
so good this looks like early new
grounds Carter no one likes you Gerry
very racially sensitive there Sweden
good job you really you really you
really did it
this is a be honest magazine everyone
watch this if I didn't know what this
was I'd be like this is some current day
weird Eastern country good like what
it's this theme song do be slapping no
hey okay I don't remember the melody I
remember I had that snail guess what the
snails name was snail sneaked it very
cool I had that I had that in would it's
whatever I was kind of a big shot this
is not a representation how the show
actually was because this is how it
looks like I like a is literally a guy
speaking years in
dude I'm not gonna sit in line to you
gosh I didn't like beards - it's funny
how I remember just spending so many
hours watching stuff that I did actually
enjoy their words with Sailor Moon but
everyone knows about Sailor Moon I love
the aesthetic of art of Sailor Moon now
as an adult but at the time I was like
girls but I didn't I didn't dislike for
the girls slicers to be real here I just
liked it because the story sucked okay
however the transformation la la
can I even show the transformation on
YouTube okay alright this is that big oh
yeah here it is here it is
bro she's naked bro bro Japan be like
bruh thanks Japan oh god I just realized
they're probably underage cut cut cut
Sailor Moon no chill huh Jesus Christ oh
my god they have Digimon can they speak
Swedish help in Sweden we usually build
up stuff as well so whenever things were
dubbed it was so confusing I was like
what's happening what if he white why is
her mouth moving with a nutter
what is that somebody's wrong here it
was like finding finding out Santa Claus
wasn't real
basically like wait what this is not
this is not that
no no see I could do a better job hire
me Digimon Swedish Russian voice actors
please hire me I will make it better I
will set things right so there you have
it Coco melon you got no chance no
chance don't even try don't even try
Coco melon I know you're scared I know
you chose not to respond but please
don't because I don't want to make this
into a thing I'm just joking it's a joke
it's joke for legal reason thanks for
watching this video if you thought this
was fun
subscribe and have a great breakfast I
kissed it that was a while ago
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]